Okay, so welcome everyone to lecture
number eight of the course. We are more
than halfway through and let's get
straight to it. We have a lot of ground
to cover today. So what have we learned
so far? We continue with our goal which
is to learn PDEs using deep learning
essentially or deep neural networks and
uh we have sort of focused or narrow
down our task to operator learning. So
what we are going to learn is
essentially the solution operator of the
BD from data and in the last couple of
lectures we have sort of focused on this
theme and we have looked at different
models different architectures FNO CNO
and so on right and what are the lessons
from that so just to recall FNO it's a
method that is based on the same sort of
style kernel integral operator so you
have a kernel integral operator which is
a convolution right so this is a linear
kernel integral operator convolution and
you implement the convolution in 4 year
space and the sort of the moral is that
your convolution is done in a non-local
manner but your activation function is
local. So this was sort of the main
message behind full operators and with
convolutional operators you flip the
script a little bit. So the convolutions
are now in physical space. So you have
the convolutions in physical space and
your activation functions are non-local.
So this was and this allows us
essentially alias free processing of
data. So this was sort of the main
differences between them. But in some
sense there are more similarities and
differences. Both of them are based on
convolutions
and uh just differ in the way in which
these computations are carried out. But
now after this sort of after having
looked at these architectures and seeing
that they perform quite well, let's now
focus on what is one of the key issues,
right? And this is a question of
scalability or scaling. What do I mean
by that? So essentially these are data
dependent methods, right? So given some
data, they're going to approximate or
learn the solution operator
the push forward with respect to the
data distribution. Now what am I showing
here is actually an interesting plot.
You'll see how important this plot will
become in due course. So what we're
doing is that if you remember this is
the Navia Stokes
uh shear layer
I think we'll see it later but I don't
want to go back to it. So in this nav
stoke she lay air. So we had this
initial conditions and then we evolved
the solution to a later time. And what
I'm interested in studying is how does
my error so in this case I have access
to the ground truth. So I know what the
error is going to be. How does that vary
when I increase the number of samples.
So what you see here is increasing the
number of samples. This is um
essentially linear scaling. This is log
linear scaling. So maybe this is the
most interesting one. So this is the log
of the number of samples
and here is the test test error. Right?
So what do we see here? So there are
three architectures that are being
compared. So the setting is exactly the
same. The operator that is being learned
is exactly the same. The data that is
given is exactly the same. The input is
the initial conditions. The output is
the solution at a later time. Right? So
this the setup is exactly the same. And
we're comparing essentially FN which is
uh where is FN? This is the one in
orange. So I use another color. Let's
use black here. So FNO is in orange. CNO
is in blue. And there's another
architecture. We don't have to focus on
that because I took it from my paper. So
I did not uh take out that architecture.
But it behaves very similarly to FNO
let's say. So now let's focus on the
orange and the blue curves here
particularly on this side of the plot.
So what do you observe? Several things
observed. First of all, we see that
there is some scaling in the sense that
if I increase the amount of data, then
my accuracy increases, right? So, this
is good news in some sense and probably
I say that on the next slide. So, yeah,
in a way success is a curve. So, this is
remember CNO and FNO. I did it with
itemize. So, this is uh what it is. So,
you can see that as the number of
samples increase in both cases, what we
observe is that the error goes more and
more down. This is on a fixed grid,
right? I'm not looking at uh
generalization across grids. I'm just
looking what happens on the training
resolution. So that's good news, right?
So that uh that it's actually a curve
and not just a point. So across the
entire sort of increasing data regime,
you can see that the error becomes
better and better and better. So this is
good news. And we also see very clearly
here that uh the rates are very similar
to each other. But FNO is consistently
better than CNO with respect to the con
CNO is consistently better than FN O
with respect to the constants. Right?
They they are these two curves are
literally parallel to each other. But
one of them has a lower magnitude to
start with than the other. So that's
that's good news. two observations the
method scale and one is you would argue
slightly better or significantly better
depending on the perspective so which
which means that in principle let's say
that I take,24 samples with fno so okay
let's take here 248 samples with fno
I can more or less get the same
performance with approximately 700
samples with CNO so it's three times
more sample efficiency
that be that as it may. So that's the
good news that there is this consistent
scaling and you will see again and again
and again that this is repeatable and
there is some theory I'm going to talk
about that but uh this is this is the
good thing let me you know what let me
just uh go here let me go here so that's
the good news that there is actually
some scaling with respect to data size
so as I said the model scale with
respect to data and in particular the
error which I denote by this uh script E
here it goes down as a function of the
number of samples n. So this is the
number of samples
and it goes down with alpha but we can
actually calculate what this alpha is.
This alpha is going to be let's let's do
the calculation for CNO for instance. So
you can see that CNO has 2% error when
it is roughly 4,96 samples and it has 1%
error when it is roughly
uh four times that. Right? So this is
16,384 samples. So this implies for CNO
at least the alpha is 0.5 right 0.5 and
similarly for FNO because these are
essentially parallel to each other. So
alpha is in some sense small and I would
argue this is a best case scenario
because theory also provides the same
thing. Can anyone give me a very very
quick indication of why you think or why
does why do you think a rate of 0.5
holds means where have you seen a rate
of 0.5 before?
Anyone has an idea
what convergence at a square root with
respect when you increase the number of
samples what converges as a square root?
No one has any idea. Yeah.
>> Can you say it loudly? Stocastic
gradient descent.
>> Stoastic gradient descent is a good
idea. But something even more elementary
than uh stoastic gradient descent. What
could that be?
>> But you are on the right track. Yeah,
follow
>> Monte Carlo.
>> Monte Carlo. That's the answer that I
was looking for. Monte Carlo. So if you
take a Monte Carlo is about stoastic
integration. So it's even before
stoastic gradient rating, right? Uh
gradient descent. It's uh essentially
sampling. So when you sample from a
distribution and you want to get the
probability density function you use
Monte Carlo and the rate of convergence
is essentially going to be 0.5 right it
is 0.5 not essentially it's
non-improvable 0.5 so this is because of
central limit theorem so in probability
theory you have the central limit
theorem which tells you that when you
sample from a distribution at best you
have a square root decay right so this
is uh so if I sample 10,000 then and if
I sample a million the decay is only by
a factor of a half by a factor of an
order of magnitude not by two orders of
magnitude right so this is the what we
learn already I hope very very sort of
elementary university math math and
statistics and this actually is more or
less it's much more hard work to show
these kind of results for these kind of
problems but it's more or less what you
observe that is slightly less than 0.5
there is some logarithmic corrections
but this is uh this is a separate matter
so at best this is going to be 0.5 five.
So what is the implication and we
observe that right and you'll see
repeatedly that this will be the
constant can change okay it depends a
little bit on the variance of the
distribution but the constant can change
but the rate is always going to be 0.5
so what is the implication of that you
are already seeing the implication of
that that to get 1% error remember that
it's square root right so 1% error
relative error is roughly 1 over 100
because 1% is 1 over 100 right so now to
get 1 over 100 what do you need? So the
square root of something which is equal
to 100 which is 100 squared that's
10,000 roughly speaking it should be of
the order of 10,000 samples because 1
overh the square root of 10,000 is 1
over 100 which is 1%. So and in this
case it's actually true to some extent
right you can see that it reaches 1%
around 8,100 no is it 8,192 okay so I
made a mistake here it's around 8,192
that it reaches 1% fn has a poor
constant right so it reaches 1% it's
still not reached 1% it's at around 2%
here so this is uh and then it will take
a factor of four more to reach 1% so
this will be 2 ^ uh or whatever. So it's
like 60,000, right? So it's uh it's a
significant uh significant number of
samples. And this is also what we are
going to consistently observe that these
models will require a large amount of
data and this is not surprising, right?
The machine learning is all about a lot
of data. You'll see how much more data
we need later on. So essentially you
need I essentially 10,000. That's that's
the order of magnitude, right? But
depending on the problem some problems
the variance which determines the
constant might be less it also depends
on the model and on the other side so it
could be anywhere between thousand to
100,000 you know to get 1% error to get
reasonable accuracy so 10,000 is a
ballpark now 10,000 seems quite okay if
I have to troll images out of the
internet and it's trivial if I have to
troll text out of the internet right
this is why in some sense large language
models work because there's a lot of
readym made data that is available. But
to generate to find that data for the
physical systems that we have, there's
exactly one physical system for which
there is uh that kind of data which is
weather and climate because people have
been observing the weather and climate
domain for a long time because we need
it. So there are there are campaigns
there are there's a lot of data storage
and it's only in this regime that you
have for instance data from 1950s very
reliable data from 1950s and let's say
the data is four times a day 6 hours
every 6 hours and 1950s to now is
already like 70 70 odd years and each
each year is 365 days if you multiply it
by four it's like 1,500 samples per day
70 years you do the math so this is so
you have the data there right you have
the data intensity of 100,000 samples
let's say or even more and then you can
use that to learn things but in general
you'll see how much how expensive it
will be to generate anywhere between
10,000 and 100,000 samples I'll already
give you a baseline number because uh
some people then at Amazon but now at
Nvidia Neil Ashton actually he generated
uh 500 simulations of some very let's
say well-resolved flow across cars,
passenger cars, and he spent something
like
approximately $2 million doing that just
to generate 500 samples, $1.5 million
doing that. So, if you had to generate
10,000 samples, that's a factor of 20 is
$30 million. No one will give you that
kind of money, right? So, this is uh
very very rare. So, the point is, and we
will come back to this issue again and
again and again that it's very difficult
to obtain that kind of large data for
PDS. This is
this is simply not not possible. So what
do we do then? So there are different
ways that we can do. We can try to
change the rate. For instance, we can
say oh can we go better than 0.5.
This is not possible because uh you know
there is uh essentially central limit
theorem. In general it's not possible.
Maybe in some specific examples you
could do but we might see some take some
sort of what's going on here now
we might take some let's say inspiration
here and we see that by improving or
changing the models we are sort of
reducing the constants maybe we can
reduce the constant even further
consistently so that by a factor of 10
is fine right so if you're between 100
and a th00and maybe it's slightly better
we will see so essentially The bottom
line is that we need our models to scale
better
somehow either by changing the the sort
of rate of convergence which I said is
non-improvable because of some theory or
by changing the constant. So this is the
this is sort of the lesson that we learn
but this is a very very important
consideration. How well does a model do
how well does a model scale with data is
what we're going to consistently observe
from now onwards. We are going to track
model behavior based on these scaling
requirements. Are there any questions at
this stage? I'd be happy to answer them.
Everyone understood. This is a very very
important point that we we need to
emphasize.
>> Okay. So yes, go ahead.
>> The scope and if so then we can model
later. How does these data needs compare
to models that can achieve say
performance for engineering problems?
Not sure which models they would be.
we will we'll we'll examine it
extensively. So as you see here already
CNO is I said factor of three or four
more data efficient right
>> so if you want to go to 1% error it
depends on what you define as your error
some people say 1% some people say 5% if
you're at 5% then this is not so bad
right because already with what is this
this is um well we can do the back
calculations so 2.5% we reach
approximately with uh 1,000 samples
Let's say so then four times that. So
256 is enough to give you to about 5%
error, right? Which is what we observe
in this regime somewhere. So that's
that's that's okay. But it whether this
is consistent for every single the rate
is consistent at best right because as I
said there are some logarithmic
corrections but the constants depend on
the data set in question. Yes.
>> Could the performance of C pro if in
some way we integrated the physics
equation we want to model
>> well you know very well that that will
not work right because we saw that with
pins that even for simple
>> is there a way to make
>> you can work on it no one has been able
to do that it's a very hard question
yeah
>> how do the convergence properties change
if we do data for each of your samples
>> uh the convergence rate will remain the
same but your constant will improve
right or not the constant will also not
improve what will imp I'm sorry what
will improve is that this number will go
somewhere here you simply have more data
>> but uh yeah we will see data
augmentation is simply not always
possible
>> right because you think that PDS have a
lot of scope for data augmentation
because there are a lot of symmetries
there is translation there is rotation
blah blah blah that's good PDS have all
these structures physical systems have
all these properties But the initial and
boundary conditions they break these
properties right so whatever is gained
by the PD itself is broken by the
initial boundary conditions coefficients
the inputs don't have these properties
so often you cannot sometimes you can
get by but often you cannot right so
remember in this transport example we
could have gotten by because this both
the both the physics itself as well as
the data could be translation invariance
so we could have used translation
invariance Okay, but in general you
cannot do that. So repeatedly this this
cannot be a solution. It's easier with
images because our brain sees even if I
rotate your face I know it's your face.
So I could classify it right but that's
not the case with physical systems. If I
rotate my inputs
uh that's it's not always because of
boundary changes and so on. It's not
always consistent. Okay. So what what
how do you scale models? Right. So in in
a way the question is uh can models or
can architectures be made to scale
better than each other right not in
terms of the rate necessarily but in
terms of constants and there is some
sort of uh let's say experience perhaps
or expertise about this and this comes
essentially from language modeling from
text and this is one of the most
influential papers ever written in
machine learning I think it came out a
bit earlier but it was published around
2020 this is by
group then at OpenAI but they are all at
anthropic now Kaplan at all and what
they observed is uh this is the same for
data models that uh traditionally the
text was processed by RNN's LSTMs and
then uh they changed to transformers the
rate is exactly the same but the
constants are different so there is a
gain of a factor of five okay so at best
you can shift the constant down and by
going from LSTMs to transformers there
seems to be a change in the constants.
So this sort of inspired people in
almost all domains at that time to move
towards transformers and today
transformers are the most popular
architecture even in the scientific
domains that we are going to talk about
more or less. So this is what is what
was the inspiration for and as I said
it's very very influential because all
LLMs that we know of they are in one way
or the other based on transformers right
so this is why I say that we need to
move towards transformers so today in
the rest of the lecture we'll almost
entirely focus on how to use
transformers to learn the operator of a
PD but that's that's that's and in the
tutorial this is also going to be
covered in the next on next Monday so
whatever you learn today you really have
to go to the tutorial so that you can
really hone and zero in on what's going
on because there are a lot of technical
things here that can only be learned
through code. Okay. So transformers it
is uh based on a mechanism. It's there
are many elements to it but the central
mechanism is something called attention.
Okay. And this is sort of the key and
there is a very nice sort of comparison
between what we did before with
convolutions and what attention can do.
It was introduced in the seminal paper
by people at Google research in 2017.
So it's a few years old now and it's
very very influential. So essentially
what attention does and this is more of
a linear algebra way of explaining and
in one slide we will have two slides we
will have a more function theoretic
operator way of explaining they are
completely related to each other. What
attention does is that it transforms
that's why the name transformer it
transforms inputs which are in the form
of vectors. So this is just what they
did right this is not necessarily what
we are going to do but just to give you
some idea of what what what the subject
is about. So just imagine that you have
let's let's look at our let's look at 1D
data. Let's say that we have the inputs
and outputs to a PTE in one space
dimension and this is given by this
domain here. Right? So this is the
domain that we have and at each point in
this domain we have a vector which is
going to explain or which featurizes the
data there. This could be for instance
temperature, pressure, velocity, stress
whatever. Right? So now you can imagine
that there are k points and at each
point there are n channels or n
features. So your total feature vector
is essentially given by this k * n
matrix or k * n 10 210 or if you want
which is given by v. So think of it as a
solution of a pd at different points and
at each point you look at different
variables temperature velocity whatever
right. So the main point of self
attention because there's something
called cross attention. Perhaps we'll
come to it in the tutorials. What self
attention does is that it takes this uh
feature which is uh v and it transforms
it into another k* n. You could change
the dimensions but for simplicity you
you just transform it by a certain uh
set of operations and you go. So this is
not necessarily a matrix. You'll see
that it's not necessarily a matrix. It's
more like a function a map which takes
this v and transforms it into u which
has the same features. So at each so k
points with n features again goes to k
points with n features. So essentially
in this blue picture here what we do is
that at each point we are going to
update the value or we going to update
the amplitude of the features that we
have. So this is roughly the idea but
how we do it is the key towards
attention. And here you have to pay
attention, right? Uh pun intended. So
what's going on? So what's going on
first of all is I want to update my
values at this point. So let's say that
this is the little k point and the
transform value is going to be called as
uk. So what I'm going to do is I'm going
to collect information from all the
points in the domain. Okay. So in
remember that with convolution we took
sort of localized points in the domain
and here with the local kernel and we
did the same with frequency space with
fno but here what we're going to do is
this is attention so we are going to
somehow get information not somehow but
we're going to get information from
every single point in the domain okay so
this is given by this vj there's a sum
over j as you can see right there are k
points in the domain there's a sum over
j and and you essentially weigh them or
you transform them by this uh what is
called a value matrix. So this is not
going to sort of mix any of these
points. Okay, there's no mixing
happening here. All that it does is that
at each point it mixes the channels,
right? So it sort of mixes the channels
and you you transform this instead of
having it. So this guy for each uh point
is a n vector. So it becomes a m vector.
m can be the same as n but let's say
that this is m vector. So essentially
all that you're doing is that I look at
all my points in the domain and say okay
I'm going to take some information out
of these points right and this is
there's no correlation between these
points. I'm not taking any any sort of
spatial correlations here. The spatial
correlations is done by this operation
here and this is the key behind
attention because otherwise this would
be just a very straightforward thing.
Right? So what we are going to say is
that in addition to these these values
that we are getting we are going to
weigh the contribution of each of these
points. Okay. So we are going to weigh
the contribution of each of these points
and these weights these depend on some
global information processing or some
coupling between these different points.
So to do that I first of all take two
matrices. Again remember that these
matrices are all pointwise. Okay. I'm
not mixing any information in space.
Again, I take them to be n * n matrices.
They need not be like this. But that's
the simplest structure. This from
language modeling these things have
names. So the matrix here Q is called a
query and the matrix K is called a key.
So essentially what I'm doing is now
let's try to focus on this picture here.
So remember that at each point I'm going
to do the relative weights, right? So
now I fix the point J. Let's say that I
fix this point. Black is probably not a
good color. I use light blue. I fix this
point J and I want to somehow weigh the
information that it conveys out here.
And how do I weigh this? What I'm going
to do is I'm going to do this
calculation here. So remember that I fix
J. I transform it. Of course, machine
learning is all about transformations,
right? So I transform it or through this
matrix K. But then I take information
from all the other points in the domain.
All the other points in the domain. So
this will give me different kinds of
weights. Tada like this. So this is the
calculation. And then to make them into
weights or probabilities I use a soft
max. So what is a soft max? So you have
a vector you want to normalize
probability is between 0 and one. Right?
So you want to normalize it between 0
and one and then you take the softmax.
You take an expo exponential at that
point and you sum everything and you
take an exponential. You see that that
automatically transforms everything to
probabilities between 0 and one. And
then so I take the information at the k
component. This is what I'm interested
in. I take a softmax and essentially I'm
done. Right? So essentially I take
information from all these points but I
weigh them based on uh spatial
correlation between different points in
the domain. Okay. So this is why it's a
double all to one mapping in some sense.
So to update the information here I
accumulate information from all the
other points in the domain but the
information that I collect from each
point is further weighted by the
relative contributions of different
points to what this guy can update.
Okay. So this is the this is the role of
um this this matrix. It's essentially a
waiting matrix. You'll see in the next
slide how it looks in an operator sense
and then things will become clear. So
ultimately this entire thing will
produce a m * n matrix at each point and
you want to go back to a n matrix. So
you just multiply n vector. So you
multiply another matrix output matrix so
the dimensions match right? So this is
essentially reshape. So remember, so
what does attention do? It's it's
weighing points, right? Or weighing
information from all the points in the
domain. That's important. But the
weights themselves are computed in a
nonlinear manner by again looking at
spatial correlations in different
points. Okay. So this is just a
combination of uh a linear operation
which is waiting but the weights being
calculated in a very nonlinear manner.
Okay. So yeah, so this is it's just an
algebraic operation. It seems to be a
very intuitive one because you just
weigh points based on their relative
importance. That's why they have this
query and key in in language processing.
This makes a lot of sense. But perhaps
for us the easiest way to understand is
to look at the infinite dimensional
perspective because we we are familiar
with functions. We are familiar with
functions too. It turns out that it is
fairly straightforward to reccast this
entire algebraic operation which is a
discrete realization of and then I can
okay multi-headed tension
maybe
uh maybe I first explain this and then
we come to multi head attention because
that's going to be straightforward right
so essentially this is what it is you
saw the picture so you have this uh
information from different points
accumulate them through a sum but weigh
them through a softmax. Right? So this
is sort of the mode in which attention
works. And if you think of it in an
operatorcentric manner like what we're
doing as a neural operator, all that you
do is that you start with a function and
then you look at its values. These are
you know if you use the same language as
in uh text in natural language
processing these are called tokens.
Okay, this is one way of thinking about
it. and then you apply them. Actually
they are featurized but uh it doesn't
doesn't make a huge difference here. And
then what you really are interested in
is that we are on a regular grid right?
So we are on a grave
and we have these tokens
at each let's say cell center
or at each point and then when we let
the grid spacing go to zero it's sort of
straightforward that this reman sum
essentially transforms into this kind of
an operator
sorry and it's easier to explain what is
going on at the level of the operator
So what do I do now? So this is a
function transforming into a function,
right? So the the exact dimensions here
doesn't really matter. So I want to
evaluate the function at the point x. So
I take information my input is given by
v. I take information from all the
points y in the domain. I'm going to
integrate over all these points. I weigh
them. But first of all, I sort of
transformed them into the right set of
coordinates through this operation here,
the value matrix. Remember that this is
completely this pointwise matrix, right?
It's completely independent of spatial
locations. Then I do this weighting.
Waiting is also multiplying this Q and K
matrices
which are pointwise. Everything here is
pointwise. But then I do this
normalization this soft max which gives
me the relative weights relative
contributions depending on spatial
correlations because what am I computing
here? I'm essentially if I did not have
this Q and K this would be just spatial
correlations between the values of these
points. In particular if a point A and a
point B have no correlations then this
would be zero. Right? So I produce the
relative weights and then to reshape I
use this matrix here. So this is the
tension and if you think of it as an
operator it's a fairly straightforward
thing. You take the you take this linear
contributions and then you use this
let's say nonlinear kernel in some sense
in order to in order to process the
information. Okay. So as I said means
the only way you can sort of understand
this better is by looking at the code
because the discrete realization of it
is given here and this will be done by
bogdan or sang in on Monday in the
tutorial but at this stage are there any
questions to this very very basic sort
of idea that you accumulate information
from all the points but you weigh them
by using the spatial correlations
between different points. That's that's
sort of the basic idea. Any questions so
far? No. And if you look at it, the
interesting thing that is happening is
that uh you can interpret this, this is
a very nice interpretation. You can
essentially interpret this as a
nonlinear kernel because of course this
is nonlinear, right? So this entire
thingy here is nothing but uh you have
this structure here because it depends
on the data vx and vy and it depends
nonlinear on the data. So this is a
kernel. So now remember that FNO CNO
these were all linear kernels right the
data itself did not matter only the
spatial location mattered whether it's a
convolution or not right so this was a
linear kernels so what we have done
through interpreting attention is by the
way the people in natural language
processing they don't care about this
right they don't think in terms of
functions they think in terms of vectors
and features and so on but for us it's
more natural in a scientific domain to
look at continum variables
Hence we use uh this kind of uh
functional setting. So then you can see
that this becomes a nonlinear kernel. So
we expect that we will gain something
when it's a nonlinear kernel right
because earlier everything was linear
and learnable because the kernel was the
convolution was learned for instance.
But now since it's nonlinear in
particular a nonlinear map can recover a
linear map right means uh this is this
is the sort of extension perhaps the
generalization of linear maps. So this
is the most important element in
attention that you have this nonlinear
kernel neural operator kernel integral
operator that is being that is being
used here. Of course it's as you'll see
it's going to be computationally heavy
but this is what what is the nature of
the beast questions? No. Uh two things
are very important to mention here.
First thing is of course you you can
interpret it like this nonlinear kernel
operator. Second thing is that the
learnable elements what is learned here
essentially
W
Q
K and uh V right. So these are the only
elements that are that are learned here
and these are all pointwise. Okay, there
is no sort of spatial correlations
between them. So in principle if you
change your resolution whatever you do
it does not really matter because these
are pointwise they're applied to each of
them. So you can change the length and
the same then there there'll be some
issues with that but at least a priority
this is not going to be that hard to
there's a question can the partition
function be ignored and leave the
normalization to the weight matrices
uh that's a very good question he's
asking do we really need to divide by
this mean in statistical mechanics it's
called a partition function
uh
yeah but that is not the same then the
interpretation changes. I think it was
Giovani who asked the question then the
interpretation really changes. It is no
longer probability.
People have different versions of this.
You know this is the most basic one but
people have different versions of this
and I'm sure that someone has considered
not normalizing and did not get good
results. Right? Because this is an
additional computational step. So I
personally like this interpretation
because it has this averaging flavor to
it. it sort of says that these are
weights. This is a nonlinear complicated
nonlinear average. So yeah, you can try
I think that's that's not very
effective. It does not have the
explicity. The second point so I said
that you can apply this Q's and K's and
V's and W's these can be all applied
pointwise. Second thing that is that
there's a very natural extension to it
which is what is called multi head self
attention. The multi head is simply when
this Q when instead of having one set of
Q, K, V and uh W, you use H of them,
right? So you have H H and then you just
weigh them differently, right? Through
this uh waiting matrix. So it's just uh
H copies of the same thing and then you
accumulate the features together. I mean
this is parallel computation in some
sense, right? And it is straightforward
to do this with respect to the
it is straightforward to do this with
respect to the attend the the operator
version of it because one can one can
easily see that uh this is this is
enough. Okay. So this is the situation
as it is. So this is the basic kernel or
the basic ingredient of transformers but
this is not enough right and why is this
not enough? Because softmax is a very
peculiar because you know we need
nonlinearities right because without
nonlinearities without activations
nothing is going to work. It's not going
to be a universal approximator right
otherwise it's nonlinear but it's this
nonlinearity is not the type of
nonlinearities that can provide
universal approximation. It's a very
mild nonlinearity. It just provides you
weights. It puts things between 0 and
one and gives you relative weights. So
in particular you need some
nonlinearities some proper activation
style nonlinearities you need some other
ingredients to sort of complete the
kernel but I suggest that we take a
short break here it's uh otherwise it
will take me another 20 minutes to just
explain that so let's take a very very
short break like 10 minutes so that we
can or we can meet at 5 and then we
provide this additional ingredients uh
so that we can complete what what a
transformer is going to
Okay. So let's uh meet at 5 then
the recording.
So what are the additional ingredients
that we need in order to convert this
into a proper approximate a proper
learner right? So as you can see in this
picture the key argument is to get some
nonlinearity and this is done by this
MLP here a feed forward network if you
want to say that right. So you need an
MLP because you need the activation to
give you this universal approximation.
So this is what we have learned so far
multi attention. In addition, we need
some normalization. Machine learning is
all about normalization. You have seen
this in your tutorials. So we also have
some normalization.
So let's look at these additional
ingredients. So first thing is
normalization because we need to
normalize the data. We need to put it
within some bounds so that you can
process the data repeatedly. Right? And
I will do this in some operator setting
but in practice this is all done
pointwise. So this is a pointwise
operation. The only sort of spatial
coupling operation is done through the
tension to the soft max. The rest of
them are just pointwise features. So
what is layer norm? So you again have a
function which layer itself is a
pointwise operation. It's a
transformation which takes n vector n
features and gets back n features. So
your input is going to be given by this
V and this is through not at every point
but at every sort of channel dimension
right. So what you do is that you
compute the mean
across the channels you compute the
standard deviation. There are other
kinds of normalizations that can be done
batch normalization instance
normalization and so on but this is what
the original uh designers of the
architecture proposed to use layer
normalization. And then you have two
learnable essentially numbers or
matrices here alpha vectors here sorry
alpha and beta is these are two vectors
and you just learn them on the way. So
you normalize the things in a learn
manner between certain bounds right and
this is done across at each point. So at
each point or at each uh location you
keep on doing this layer normalization.
It's a straightforward thing. It's just
one one function in PyTorch right layer.
So this is uh this is a very very simple
operation but this is not enough because
this just normalizes things. So what we
really need is this MLP but this can
also be done pointwise right. So I keep
on repeating that these are all
pointwise operations. So this is also
where you use the MLP pointwise right
here. So in operator interpretation what
you do is that given an input uh at each
point x you're going to put a pointwise
MLP. Remember that the number of
features of course is given by some n
right. So you take this multiply it with
the weight matrix which is d * n d is
the hidden dimension add a bias vector
which is a d- dimensional vector. So
this becomes uh the whole thing becomes
a d-dimensional vector. Apply an
activation. This could be relu time
hyperbolic or whatever jlu whatever
there are different kinds of activation
el different kinds of activation
functions that you're going to use and
then you come back to Rn by using this u
output matrix essentially. So this is
done at every single point. So at every
single point you normalize and then you
put this pointwise MLP and this will be
enough okay this will be enough to
provide universal approximation
properties. So essentially we are done
because uh we also have some residual
connections. This is to ensure better
training. So so you can think of an
operator transformer block. This will be
multiplied many times over but the basic
block is the following. So you start
with an input function. Okay, you apply
this multi head self attention. So self
attention is this nonlinear kernel and
you do it with multi heads. You take 10
copies of this and club them together.
So this is sort of straightforward. So
there you go. So this is the first step.
Then you normalize of course uh but this
is not enough because you also put a
skip connection. So the skip connection
so remember that my input is given by V.
So and my output is going to be given by
U here. So you take a skipped connection
with the transformer then you uh not
with the transformer with the tension
then you learnably remember that this
layer norm is just channelwise and
pointwise. So you apply this you get a U
hat as a consequence of this then you
put it through an MLP
pointwise right so this is what is going
to give you the universal approximation
properties
and then again you have another layer
norm okay so this is the skip connection
here's the skip connection you you had
and this is what the MLP gives you and
then some layer norm and you get the
output and we are going to stack blocks
and blocks after this right so you have
attention which is applied in a global
manner because there is this mixing. Of
course, each of these components are
going to be pointwise. So you can apply
them to a different set of points if you
want. Then you put all these layer
norms, skip connections, uh then feed
forwards. All of these are pointwise
operations. So this can be done done
very very in a very straightforward
manner. Okay. So this is going to be the
basic structure of the of the of this um
let's say operator transformer but in
general a transformer. So you understood
why we need the feed forward right feed
forward is essentially to provide MLPS
to provide nonlinear activations so that
without that there is no chance of
universal approximation and
normalization is bread and butter of
machine learning so that you want your
inputs and outputs to have similar
ranges roughly speaking right. so that
you can easily process them. All of this
is you can think of them as
transformations. So you take your input,
you transform it into the output by a
series of steps. So only key step here
that is sort of different from what we
had before is this multi head attention.
This is where the coupling takes place,
right? The global coupling, this
nonlinear kernel integral operator, it
takes place there. Any questions on
these other ingredients so far? No. But
there is one little catch. I don't know
how many of you have caught it. The
catch is that there is total so far what
I have described to you. There's total
permutation invariance. There's no sense
of position whatsoever. What do I mean
by that? So remember that these things
are anyway the MLPS the residual
connections the
what is it the layer norms these are all
point wise right? So if I flip the order
of the points the they will be totally
invariant means uh it does not really
matter whether I have points in one
order and another order I can shuffle
the points all together. Also the
attention itself is a then this is a
good exercise for you to do. For
instance you can think of it in the
integral way or you can think of it
through the pointwise way. So here is an
exercise
I write it here. Check that
attention is permutation invariant. It's
straightforward.
Permutation invariant.
So what does that mean? That if I flip
the positions, the output is going to be
exactly the same. Right? So I can flip
the positions in whatever way that I
want to because we are doing a softmax
which is translation invariant. No
position permutation invariant and we're
doing a sum which is also permutation
invariant. And this is not good news for
us because if we have no sense of
position. So remember that our inputs
and outputs also for images or text or
for anything. This is a problem. So
remember that we might have an input or
output which looks like this. And now
what attention is saying is that I can
flip these points whatever way is
possible. So in particular I can take
this point put it in the center and take
this point here put it here. Just switch
the positions. Then my function changes
in a very very discontinuous manner.
Well, this is a smooth change but it
changes in a very nasty manner and you
cannot means physics is not permutation
invariant nor are images permutation
invariant nor is text permutation
invariant and so on. If I say I am
having a headache now which is actually
true then I I can't say that I now
headache have okay you can still make
some sense of it but if I even take head
and ache because each of them correspond
to different I now ache head ache have
head this doesn't make any sense right
so you cannot do permutation invariance
in that way it's the same with images if
you jumble around all the pixels of my
face you'll get something uglier than
what I look anyway but uh so It's sort
of you cannot do this. So there has to
be some sense of position. This is the
important important point. It could be
absolute or it could be relative means
uh relative position is also fine
because you can rearrange things
accordingly. Right? So you need some
notion of uh position absolute or
relative position and this is uh already
the designers of attention they
understood that that you cannot do this.
So you need some what are called
positional encodings and these are as
important as that tension matrix itself.
So what is positional encoding? Let's
try to understand that. It tells the
architecture the model that okay this
point is having a certain order compared
to this point compared to this point and
so on. It gives you some coordinate
information if you want to think of
right. So how do you do that? So the way
you do it is through again through some
MLPS essentially means this is this the
basic idea. So now imagine that I'm just
talking about it in the vector form.
This can be easily put into an operator
form that's that's not an issue. So what
you do is that you have your input
VK right you transform it you put them
through an MLP. So this is not the key
point because this is uh anyway
permutation invariant. But what really
matters is that you provide here the
absolute position. You say that I'm
ordering these points according to a
certain order and this is the kth unit
vector. So this point for instance this
is my 10th point. So it will only be one
in the 10th component and zero
elsewhere. This sometimes is also called
a one hot vector
in computer vision natural language
processing. So you say that this is my
first point. So it's one. All the rest
127 points are zero. Then this one is Z
one in the second location. All the rest
127 coordinates are zero and so on and
so forth. So this gives you absolute
position. You can easily make it
relative by fixing a reference point and
so on. And then you have a bunch of
weight matrices, right? And these are
learnable position encodings. We'll have
different examples of position
embeddings later on. So this provides
you with some sense of position learned
sense of position and this is very very
important is that it's a very simple
thing right it says that this is the
ninth member of the sequence or set of
points this is the 27th member this is
the 54th member now nothing is
permutation invariant because that
information is there that it's the 54th
member but I could have also done it by
using relative position coordinates I
could say that okay I fixed my first
coordinate and compared to that it's my
53rd member number or I fix my middle
coordinate and compared to that it's the
26th member on the right or the left. So
there are different ways to do it and in
fact in practice people don't even use
learnable in the original paper they
they use some fixed position encodings
the s and cosine position encodings but
we will we generally have this learnable
one which is the most general one. So
this completes the description because
now you have the entire block. You can
interpret it as functions. You can
represent it or sort of realize it
computationally as vectors and it's
exactly the same sort of u sort of
behavior. So you have some inputs. So of
course you embed the inputs, right? This
is your projection and lifting operators
that you're very very familiar with. You
provide positional encoding. Tell the
architecture that this is my 9th point.
This is my 27th point. This is my 56
point and so on. Apply multi head
attention. Apply the layer norm. Um then
uh of course have the skip connection.
Then apply feed forward. Apply the layer
norm again. Skip connection. And this
gives you one block and you stack it up
10 blocks. Yeah. Go ahead.
>> Um attention works great with one. We
need to keep uh in the attention all of
the tokens it's squared. So if we use
PDS that are either
>> so one one one slide after this okay
>> okay
>> so you preempted one slide we we
precisely come to that point but just
imagine that we are able to
do it let's say let's fix that's why I
started out with 1D right so in 1D you
have a sequence of tokens of pointwise
information and you keep on transforming
it keep on transforming it keep on
transforming it the key point is you can
apply it two different set of points
because each of these learnable elements
is anyway uh going to be uh is anyway
going to be um no it's pointwise so you
can do that positional embeddings are an
issue that's why you resize the inputs
we have already learned that through CNO
that you resize the inputs and then you
get back you get back to the original
grid and you can apply the you can apply
the architecture but this is something
that will be explained but now coming to
your question any further questions in
the basic architecture. Let's look at
its negatives in one second. But what
are what is the basic construction means
after all you have to go and write some
basic code on how to do this, right? So
you have to understand the throughput uh
the flowchart and so on. Is that clear?
Okay. So let's uh precisely come to his
point, right? What is what is the issue?
The issue is very clear means if you it
goes back to the very definition itself
that this is an expensive operation,
right? So you can see maybe the easiest
is when I had the picture this one.
So how many operations do I need to do?
So to update at this point I need to
calculate the or I need to get
information from K points or K tokens.
So that is order of K. But for each of
these K points I again need information
from all the K points. All right. So the
total amount of information is again
this is order of K. So for each of this
K and then K of these. So the total
thing is going to be order of k squ. So
the compute is going to be order of k
squ. And if you're a little bit more
careful, you can try it at home
yourself. Where is it now? You can see
that the total compute it scales in the
following manner. K square comes in
that's the most dominant one. But that's
not the only one. We also have the
number of features, right? n that comes
in and m is going to be the hidden
dimension because uh we we had some uh
remember that in the query and the key
and so on we transform to a m
dimensional space right
so now m can be equal
24 or 64 or something like that that's
not the challenge the challenge is that
there is a k squ here but still there
are some possib positive things about uh
the current architecture which is that
there is a lot of parallelism again it's
difficult to explain it unless until you
show it in code and this is what
is going to do in the next lecture so
the number of sequential operations is
all of these things can be done in
parallel this queries keys and so on
they can all be learned in parallel and
the sequential operations and path
length are essentially of order one
that's why attention or transformers
work so well because you know all about
modern GPUs is parallel computation,
right? So you sort of uh break the
computation into little pieces and let
different parts of the GPU do this and
combine them. And this is ideally uh
sort of easy to implement on GPUs. And
it's the confluence between the
expressivity of the architecture and its
ability to scale to GPUs that has made
this very very popular. Nonetheless, the
challenge still remains formidable in
terms of the compute. Right? So now
let's put some representative numbers on
K. Remember that for us K is the number
of points. So 100 points. Okay, if you
have 100 points, this is too little.
Let's say 100. Let's work with 100
points in 1D. The scaling is forget
about the M andN and say that they're of
order one.
Let's say together they're of order 10.
K squ is still 10,000. So each block is
going to be 10,000. Let's say that it's
100,000 because you have this M andN are
of the order of 10. So you're stacking
up five of them. 500,000 no big deal. So
1D this is a very very effective choice.
As soon as you go to 2D what happens is
that you have 100 squared points. Now
you take this 100 squared points you
flatten them into a sequence which is uh
going to be 10,000. The sequence length
is going to be 10,000. Now k squar is
100 million. You have a 10 on top right?
So each layer becomes 1 billion and you
have five layers you have five billion
means hardly anyone has worked in this
setting right there very very few I
think our largest models so far in my
lab have been around 2 and a half
billion right but maybe in 2D this can
be done now look at 3D 3D
1000 squared is 100 cubed now right so
that's a million so the sequence is
going to be a million dimensions so
million* a million billion is a bill uh
a trillion no billion no trillion a
trillion so you're out right means
almost immediately you're out means even
open AI is not going to be able to do
that mean even so this is infeasible
okay so the way it is it's infeasible
this m andn are not less than one they
are actually of significant order
themselves you know because the number
of hidden dimensions and the number of
uh hidden features sort of express
unique need this at least to be 16
squared for instance. So this is totally
infeasible even in 2D because in 2D we
already calculated that this was in in
the order of billions. We are not we not
going to do that. So this is not the way
to do it as you pointed out for text it
is not a problem because text is
essentially one-dimensional or DNA
sequences are one-dimensional RNA is
one-dimensional. So a lot of Wikipedia
or the entire Wikipedia is I don't know
it's some terabytes of data. It's not a
lot you know it's it's text is very very
sparse data right whereas uh our
modalities are much more rich in some
sense because we even have 3D modalities
right but there's one domain which is
already sort of where this is in
feasible and that is vision so images so
even if you take a very coarse modern
images are like thousand by thousand
resolution thousand pixels right so this
already a million points but even if you
take 100 by 100 it's 10,000 and you are
in this infeasibility domain
So pretty uh quickly after transformers
was introduced by people in Google and
they were mostly sitting in Mountain
View people here in Jurich they in the
Google research they came up with an
architecture that can scale to images
right and this led to and we can adapt
that uh and this led to what are called
vision transformers
and this is what we are going to use
extensively in the course and the idea
behind vision transformers is very very
very simple. Let me try to explain it
through a picture and then we can do the
math. Right? So the idea behind vision
transformers it's very similar to what
are called finite volume methods means
those who are from computational science
probably know this. So the idea is so
now you have your input. So this this
figure has a lot of information but
let's let's try to condense the
information. So you have the black uh
box is your domain. Okay. The big black
box is your domain. And now if you think
of it in terms of points uh I could have
taken sort of small number of points and
so on and this would have been I don't
know 64 by 64 points. So 64 squared is a
very large number and is that 4,96.
Yeah. So already it's it's a it's a
pretty large number and you cannot can
cannot apply attention there. So what
these people uh from Google and Jurich
they argued is that you don't need that
kind of fine scale pointwise
information. What you can do is that you
can essentially average that information
locally. And this is done by a process
which is called batching. Some people
also call it as patchification.
But I would simply say that it's a very
simple averaging procedure. So what you
do is that you take your domain, your
computational domain for instance, you
break it down into little boxes, cells.
So this you can think of it. So this
thing is called a patch in the language
of um of image processing of computer
vision but I would call it as a cell in
my language. Okay in the scientific
language it is scientific computing
language it's a cell and then all that
you do is that you learn an average. So
you have many pixels. So they they did
so they they had images right 128x 128
and their patch was uh over 16x 16 16 x
16 of these pixels they took that
information and they sort of transformed
it into a single feature or a set of
features and that is sort of the basis
and now you apply attention not to the
information pointwise information but
the batch wise information right so how
do you do that so just imagine that you
have a image uh this is from images and
I will do the same for operators in a
second. So the resolution is H over W.
Let's say that this is 128 by 128,
right? Most images are square images.
And then you also have channels, right?
The number of features that you have. So
the total information is hidden in this.
Okay. Already you can see that I have
assumed that W equal to H. So that
things are Yeah, exactly. So this things
are simpler. Then you divide it into uh
so you take some each of these patches.
You can make them uniform. Later on we
will work with something which is
non-uniform but you take them to be p by
p. So the total number of patches is
essentially h² by p ^ 2 right. So just
imagine that you have a 128x 128 image
and you are each of these patches of
size 16 x 16. So 128 x 128 uh divided by
16 x 16 is 8 * 8 64. So there are 64
batches right? So that's the number of
batches. And now the information from
these patches is what is put into a
sequence. So there's a lot of
condensation compression of information.
There are other ways to do it but this
is the simplest way to do it. And then
you each of these is still having C
channels right? It's it could be more
channels but it each of these is going
to be C channels. But now it's very very
important to give you some sense of uh
positional information or patch
information. So you take what are called
batch embeddings. You transform this and
you put it into a set of tokens, set of
patch tokens. So think of each of these
as a learned local average.
Learned local average.
And then the number of tokens is reduced
considerably by a huge factor. Instead
of 4,96, you come to 64. 64x 64 is a
manageable number, right? So you can you
can readily transform it. And then these
are what are fed into a transformer. So
it's really learned local ager. Is that
clear? Yes. Go ahead.
>> Uh generally after okay so it tells you
the relative information or the position
of the patch rather than the position of
the I think there is something which it
it's coming. Okay. You in principle you
can apply it before but then the
semantics is somehow lost because within
the patch but how does it matter right?
because anyway I'm taking an average
right so when I'm taking an average I'm
summing of information without sort of
distilling different points so this this
is so this is the key trick and this is
the architecture that bogdan is or sen I
don't know one of these are going to
boys are going to present this on on
Monday on in in the tutorial so you can
write everything in terms of operators
there is some math here uh I probably
have to rush a little bit so I don't
have to go through but you can see what
is going on right so it's a weighted
average so the way I think of it is a
weighted average and the waiting is done
in terms of direct masses essentially so
it's a it's a weighted average as you
can see and then it's transformed by
some learnable matrix right so these are
your patch embeddings so and the weight
is going to be the same function that is
applied in different uh across different
patches so again think of it as
essentially learned local averages that
are fed into the transformer. That's
that's the rough rough idea. And then
there are the positional encoding as it
says it comes after the patch
embeddings. So you have an input now
it's a function with uh cd dimensional
features and for simplicity I took it in
R2. There is uh you can do the same
thing in 3D also. In 1D there is no
point. You can also do it in 1D but why
should we do that? it's in 3D you can do
the same thing but just for notational
simplicity and in the course we are
mostly going to at least for the
exercises will be in 2D I'll show you 3D
results but uh this is not not essential
so you have a domain cartician domain
for simplicity right because you could
make it rectangular but let's say that
this is this is a square so then you
take a sequence of operators so you take
the batch embedding so this is your
batch embedding you add the positional
encoding on top. This is where the the
key feature is and the usual sort of
layer norm multi head self attention
residual layer norm MLP residual and
then you do the processing maybe I have
a picture no I don't have a picture but
uh I don't need a picture here it's very
very clear what's what's going on so the
only difference from what we did before
was that now the the you you do inputs
and you do batching here and then batch
embedding
and then everything goes. So this is a
very very simple idea, right? It's it's
a very very simple idea and they were
able to sort of scale it. I think the
paper is called learning images using 16
by 16 words or something, right? So it's
really sort of this uh transformed
images into sequences and then you can
you can learn through that.
Okay. uh and we will see several
examples with vision transformers but uh
there is still a still a catch of course
as you can see the compute is reduced
considerably as soon as the patch size
is uh large you you can down the compute
dramatically right so remember as I said
if I started with a let's let's do a
mental experiment so now instead of
having let's say we have 100 by 100 grid
but we reduce it into 10x 10 batches
right so earlier we add 100 by 100. So
10,000 tokens. 10,000 * 10,000 is 100
million. And if you have uh five blocks,
you do the math yourself. It's it's
several billion. Right? Now I say that I
take this 100 by 100 image or 100 by 100
points and then I put it into 10 by 10
patches. Right? So 10x 10 patches means
that I'll only have 100. And then 100 *
100 is 10,000. And even if you have your
MN to be large, this is still of the
order of a few hundred thousand which is
a completely affordable architecture. So
what was a billion got reduced
considerably right? So the key thing is
so the key variable here. So the compute
can go down dramatically for the right
patch size. So essentially everything
depends on the patch size which is your
P. So if your P is a large value like 16
by 16 you have a huge reduction in the
number in the in the dimension and so so
here I'm assuming P is it's P squ so
it's 16 then you have a huge reduction
but now this is okay for images because
if you take an image which is a high
resolution image 1,000 by,000 and you
break it down into six I take 16 by 16
pixels and average them not much is
going to be lost right because images
are such higher means you don't need
very very fine resolution in images in
order to make a decision about them that
whether it is me or you, it does not
really rely on that fine information.
But for our data, this could be an
issue, right? Because if you take two
large batch sizes, you reduce the
compute considerably, right? So that's
the advantage. You reduce the compute
considerably. But the negative is that
then you might lose information and
maybe you lose too much of information.
In fact, we rarely go below 8 by 8
batches. 16 by 16 doesn't work because
you average out a lot. Okay. So, as long
as the batch size is large, the compute
is under control. However, you lose
information. As long as the batch size
is small, so for instance, if your batch
size is two, so you're breaking it into
4x4, then the compute can blow up, but
you keep information. So there are these
two factors that are always sort of
fighting against competing against each
other there's some sort of a parto front
essentially and the bottom line is that
it's still not particularly in 3D if you
have very small batch sizes this is
still not scalable even though I would
say that this is quite a satisfactory
architecture but we can do even better
or we can we can improve it and there's
one simple trick to improve it which is
what I'm going to show
But there's not one. There are many many
different tricks on how to improve it.
But did you understand what is the
bottleneck here? Because uh as always we
it's compute versus accuracy. Right? So
this is how these two things balance is
the trick of the trade in this entire
business in numerical analysis,
scientific computing, machine learning.
These considerations remain equally
important. Whatever be the state
questions? Any further questions? Yes.
So the output resolution is basically
the level of edges there.
>> You can always come back to the to the
original resolution that is just a
linear transformation. Okay, it's a
recovery operation. That's a good
question. That's a that's a recovery
operation. Once you have a matrix, you
can uh you can you can sort of recover
pointwise values. But it's a very very
good question. So you can you can come
back to the original resolution. That's
that's not an issue. Further questions.
This is at the very end. you know you
keep on doing it and then at the very
end you do so this is uh okay so at
least I'll show you one trick because uh
then I have some results and again
people in imaging they they have dealt
with this again and again and again
right so they have come out with many
ideas gated linear attention they have
uh group query attention flash attention
linear attention performer there are
many many different ideas but uh let me
show you one okay this is not the only
idea let me show you one this again
comes from image imaging because they
they they had the same kind of
questions. So this is where my second uh
block and this has sort of it is related
to what are called domain decomposition
methods in numerical analysis. So I sort
of like it uh from that that that
perspective. So what do you do? So
instead of having one level of
discretization you will have two levels
of discretization. The first level of
discretization are these white boxes
right? These are your patches.
So these guys they are from I think at
that time they were at Microsoft in
Beijing. So what they came up with is
that the second level of discretization
and these are these big black boxes.
Okay and these are called windows.
So for us these are cells at two
different resolutions. So what they said
is that the difficulty is this global
compute right? because you are taking
all these sequences and you are rel each
member of the sequence is weighed with
respect to every other member of the
sequence that's why you have a quadratic
cost. So what if instead of applying
attention in the across the entire
domain we only of course we take we take
it in batches but we only apply it in
inside each window. So in so we sort of
break this global computational
complexity and make it sort of local but
at a wider level of resolution. Right?
So the number of windows is of course
much less than the number of patches. So
what do you do? So instead of applying
attention, so this is the formula. So
earlier remember that this was the full
domain. Now it is actually the window
that you have. So in particular, let's
think of this particular window or let's
say this window. So all that you do is
that you take these um 16 patches and
you only apply attention across these 16
patches. So each of these 16 patches is
being attended to when I am updating the
information here. But no information
from this this and these points is
coming in. Okay. So this is not a global
method. It's a local method. It's a
little bit like convolution. But then
the whole beauty of attention was the
fact that you could do this kind of
global information processing, global
information transfer. And this is where
their ingenuity really came in. So what
they said is okay, this is a layer-wise
architecture anyway. So and we have
we're going to stack several layers. So
what we are going to do is that in one
layer we have this arrangement of
windows. We have this domain and in the
next layer we're simply going to move
the windows. So what happens is so this
is layer one and you can keep on
sequentially moving it and in layer two
you go to this. So these two points
which were never sort of interfering
with each other in level one in level
two they are sort of uh interacting with
each other. and this point and this
point which were not are doing it
because these two are in the same
window. You know you have to rearrange
things so that the so that the coverage
so you change the windows in such a
manner so that you get global coverage
and you keep on doing it in a sequential
manner very very simple idea right so
you still have this batch structure the
compute is now not in terms of batch
size but in terms of the window size so
what is the window size here I don't
remember the notation but okay maybe
it's m is a window size so it's it's
sort of quadratic with respect to that
and then you sort of uh shift windows
across layers right so if you have like
eight windows the computation doesn't
break down it's still with respect to
the number of windows and you can do
this so if you want small patch sizes
then you have to use this sliding
windows in order to get global
information and I think this will also
hopefully be covered in the tutorial and
there are some modifications for
scalability you can use relative
position coordinates instead of using a
dot product that we had used before you
can use cosine distances but these are
these are sort of minor minor points
it's I I don't want to bother you with
this details so essentially the idea is
that we can sort of scale transformers
and apply them to our domains not just
in 2D but as you'll see in 3D and there
are many many versions of it but the one
that I can talk about most
authoritatively is the one that came out
from my lab which is called scalable
operator transformer it was proposed
last year I think I even mentioned
mentioned it in the lectures last year.
So this was last year around this time
that it was it was proposed. So this is
based on a windowed self attention
patchbased vision transformers. So swim
this is sifted windowed attention spin.
Okay. And the interesting thing here is
that we do it in this usual um you know
this multiscale manner just like you do
with unit. So you start with a input you
do an embedding you apply attention
blocks but you do it in a multiscale
manner. So like in a unit you you apply
attention blocks you go down to a
bottleneck and you go up. So this
encoder decoder architecture and in
between you have some convolution based
rest nets connets okay but that's not so
you do how do you go down and go up you
keep on merging the patches and you keep
on expanding the patches. So now coming
back to your question, you automatically
go back to the original resolution. So
this is a very natural way to do that.
We can also prove just like before that
this is a universal approximator. As
long as you have any continuous operator
then this kind of fancy architectures
can also approximate it and the compute
is controlled because we have the
shifting windows. So we could scale this
to 3D without without any problems as as
you will see. Okay. Are there any
questions? Means there's a lot of
information today but perhaps this is a
detail right what is important is the
vision transformer because this is sort
of a basis of uh what is going on and as
long as your patch sizes are relatively
large you can still apply them. Okay so
let me just quickly run through some
results so that uh you get a sense of
what's going on. So this is the pos
equation minus lelassian of u equal to f
and the operator simply takes f to u
which means that if I take these forcing
terms like this this is how the solution
looks like I change the location and the
intensity of the gausians go to
something like this they diffuse out
right here there's only one gausian so
it will only locally diffuse out and the
same here so this is precisely the
behavior of the possonic equation
and now we tried different versions of
it fn Don't ask me for the exact size
but these are in the order of a few
million. Okay. So this is FNO maybe 10
or 15 million parameters. CNO which is
here uh the blue one is CNO and there
are two versions of Scott. One is with
20 million. So this I think are
approximately 40 million parameters and
this guy the green one is 20 and the
orange no the orange one is 20 and this
one is 40 maybe. So something something
in this in this range. So what do you
see? So here it's quite interesting. FNO
as always I don't say it does a poor
job. It does a good job. It scales with
data but there is a distinct difference
between it and CNO. CNO actually scales
slower. So what is interesting is in the
small data regime CNO is the best
architecture. As you can see it does
better than transformers but the
transformers catch up and they catch up
more quickly. In this particular case
they have better convergence properties
than CNO. So if you have,024 sample
let's say that you have 4,96 samples
that's too much but you can see that
they are significantly superior to the
other architectures. So we are very
encouraged by hey this is exactly what
you observe in language modeling that
the error goes down not the error itself
but the you can see that these are
essentially parallel lines but the
constants go down but that's not
necessarily true. This is another
example. This is Elmo's equation. So you
have minus llassian of u plus omega^ 2 u
= f. f is given here. The operator is f2
u. So f is given here. And the frequency
is like four I think. So you can see
that the solution changes like this.
These are different different harmonics.
Again the same same experiment. Now
there is not again FNO is not as good
here as CNO and U and the transformers
but they are all bunched together. So
there is no difference between CNO and
transformers but there is it's also not
uh there's no harm either. The compute
for the transformers because of the swin
and so on is similar to that of CNO.
Okay, there's no no difference. Wave
equation again similar. This is from
initial conditions and coefficients to
the solution at a later time. And you
see the that this is the output and what
do we observe actually in this case they
are very very similar maybe this is
scaling slightly better but there is
there's not a not a huge difference uh
this is Navia Stokes this is our classic
example Navia Stoia layer no daylight
between them they are very very similar
to each other and they are superior to
FNO but they are they are very very
similar to each other so in fact we did
this across many many different PDS 15
actually I'll come back to this in the
last lecture 15 operator learning tasks
and these numbers essentially more here
is better more here is better and you
can see that they are very very similar
to each other so all this hard work and
the inference time is also the same
means you don't uh all that we have done
is that we have changed our perspective
instead of using convolution we have
transformers this will be useful later
on as you will
But at this very elementary level,
nothing changes. They're not more
expensive, but they're not more accurate
either. It's just a different way of uh
solving the same problem. Okay. So, I
think I stopped here a bit early but uh
bit early than late and I'm happy to
take any questions. So, what will happen
in the next tutorial is that the vision
transformer will be explained right. But
that means that all the patchification
uh self attention layer norms uh
position encodings all these modules
will be MLPS residuals all of them will
be explained also maybe this multiscale
structure will be shown so that you come
back to the original resolution and then
you get a get a good handle of what
transformer is about. So what I'm going
to do in the next lecture is that I will
now try to make things more and more
complicated. So now for 2D we have
different kinds of architectures. we
have a basic understanding then we'll go
to time dependent problems to complex
grids to 3D to multiscale problems and
so on so that we up the ante in every
lecture okay uh do you have any
questions uh also from the zoom are
there any yes go ahead
is also useful for inverse problems
>> yes very much we will do that at some
point if there is time otherwise you can
always talk to me it's very much because
the inverse operator is also an
operator. So right so in this case uh
this for instance for the helm's
equation this is or let's look at the
posaw equation right this is very simple
that you give this uh here and you want
to go back here is not not unique but
there are some some ways to recover
uniqueness and so on it's very very
useful for because inverse operator is
really an operator so you can you can
define it further questions no okay so
let's take a early stop today and we
meet again on but please do go to the
tutorial on Monday because it's very
very important to learn how transformers
are coded.